اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم
هجومنا بثلاثه مسيرات يستهدف مصنع عسكريا
في محافظه اصفهان الايرانيه وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه اعلنت احباط الهجوم دون تحديده
هويه الطائرات وقالت ان الاضرار اقتصرت
على سقف المصنع لكنها اكدت مواصلتها انتاج
كل ما يلزم لتعزيز قوه البلاد وامهم
يا اولي تنفيذ لقرارات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الانتقاميه ضد الفلسطينيين
الاحتلال يغلق منزله اسره منفذ عمليه نفي
يعقوب في القدس وحراس مستوطنه كيدومين
يقتلون شابا في الضفه الغربيه
توسيع الاستيطان بالتزامن مع جوله وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي في المنطقه
تحركاتنا عسكريه في اوكرانيا استعدادا
لهجوم محتمل في الربيع روسيا حولت هجماتها
في الشرق
لتامين خطوط الامداد واوكرانيا اكدت انها
تتفاوض مع حلفائها للحصول على مقاتلات
وصواريخ بعيده المدى والمتحدث باسم قواتها
الجويه يقول للجزيره ان طائرات الاوكرانيه
بحاجه ماسه للتحديث
مبيعات الهواتف الذكيه في الصين تنخفض
لادن مستوى منذ 10 اعوام بتراجع عن قدره
13 في المئه على اساس ثانويه هذا تراجع
ياتي نتيجه تتوخي المستهلكين في الانفاق
وتواسيا مع اداء القطاع حول العالم الى
اللقاء